[Music]
this
is star talk i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist
this is going to be a cosmic queries
edition and of course that means i have
chuck
chuck helping me out here hey neil how
you doing
i'm yeah i'm excited for this one yeah
this one this is like this is very cool
there's gonna be a happening cosmic
queries you know why because
uh normally when the expertise falls
outside of
anything i know we of course bring in an
expert but this time we've got
two experts two experts
and why because they're both the subject
of a recent documentary
called fathom fathom
and it's a groundbreaking story to learn
how to talk to whales wow
how to talk to whales and i've got with
me ellen garland and
michelle fournade i pronounced that
right welcome
thank you so much both of you guys and
so you're each phd
marine ecology oh michelle you're marine
ecologist
and ellen you're a marine biologist do i
get that right
yes okay okay and so so i didn't know
you can get a
separately a phd as a marine ecologist
from because we've all heard of marine
biology right but marine ecology that a
new field
that we hear of i mean if i was going to
be really specific my phd is actually in
wildlife science which means that i
focus specifically on studying
animals in the wild in their natural
habitat um
instead of in houses or zoos or homes
i got it okay but but but okay how about
humans uh when i'm in the city that's my
habitat
and you can study humans like just as
they
gather into cities in the wild which
which by the way
is nothing more than an open range cage
let's let's just call it but that's true
that's true
we put ourselves we put ourselves cages
so michelle you're a postdoctoral fellow
at cornell
that's right up upstate new york in
ithaca and
you specialize in animal communication
and
marine bio acoustics i like that i love
new words that where it's clear what
you're saying
you don't have to say what does that
mean bio acoustics figure it out
we got that uh it's a really
like laid back whale with a guitar and a
cocktail party
a bio acoustics
acoustic yeah mtv unplugged it's a
fantastic thing
um and uh ellen you are a marine
biologist
uh research fellow at the university of
saint andrews in
scotland scott but you're not scottish
where where are you hail from
no no i'm not scottish um i'm originally
from new zealand so i'm a
i'm a kiwi but i've had to i've moved
all over the world so
i don't have as strong a kiwi accent
though i feel it may come out today a
little bit
but a few certain words will come out
we'd love to hear a little bit uh
you have like a residual kiwi accent we
love new zealand nobody doesn't love new
zealand
everybody loves what is it about new
zealand because they filmed
the lord of the rings there that's why
it could be that could be
it okay yeah no i'm sure there are other
reasons but well
it's a beautiful country it's it's it's
lovely and green and there's a lot of
you know ocean there so i i definitely
grew up around that
this this new documentary we're talking
about which uh i'm
told is uh being entered into film
festivals but also
uh will come out on apple tv plus i
think they call
call that channel now um the director of
the film
drew xanthopoulos i think i pronounced
his name right
he describes this film as uh a rival
but with whales remember the arrival
visitation except that one had like like
you know septopods in it or right like
seven
limbed octopuses and this one has whales
okay uh okay we would be the arrival for
whales
like oh we wouldn't be good whales
wouldn't be the arrival we'd be the ones
who landed
ooh and wants to talk and we want to
land and talk
okay so let's let's get to the bottom of
this let me ask you guys and i don't
know who to direct it to so you all just
you know fight each other and then you
know whoever's still speaking
what uh each of your specialties is
the communication methods and tactics of
these creatures who bear the largest
brain of any living creature that ever
was on earth
so uh but we hear the sounds they make
but
why are you so so convinced that we can
crack that code
oh well for my part i'm not but um any
good anything well
okay well then what that's the end of
the interview well
thanks thanks for tuning in people
this has been star talk with michelle
fournette and ellen garland
i certainly appreciate it well but it's
worth a good try right any good question
is worth is worth trying to answer and
when you're dealing with something
bigger than yourself and other than
yourself
then you you put in the very best of
what our slightly smaller human brain
has to offer
and so for the work that i do the best
that i could do wasn't to say i'm going
to tackle all humpback wheel
communication at once
i started with a very tiny piece of the
puzzle
and i said what does this one sound
mean and so if you start small the hope
is eventually you can get big
before you shoot for the stars you have
to make it to the moon
interesting okay and so so you got a
little a little piece of the
sound and then what did you find
well this is the kind of cool thing i
found that i mean it seemed simple but i
found that whales talk to each other
and that if you do but did we need you
to figure that out i mean come on now
did you guys actually i learned that
from ellen
in nemo
[Laughter]
the answer is the answer to that is
decisively yes this is one of the first
times in human history
that we have actively gone out and
designed an experiment to try and figure
out exactly what a whale does
when you when it talks to itself so when
one whale talks to another whale how do
they respond
why is that important why is this whale
producing a sound
and to do that we had to go out and drop
a speaker in the water and produce a
sound that a whale would make
to see is this an exchange or is this a
whale trying to find fish
or is this a whale that's trying to
navigate or is this a whale that's
trying to keep itself company i mean you
have to remember that
and i do my work in alaska so southeast
alaska it's in the summertime
lots of primary productivity which means
the water is completely cloudy
no light a whale that is 10 meters away
from another
whale is invisible unless it makes a
sound
wait what kind of activity is there did
you say primary productivity
so wait say that word again
primary production primary production
activity plankton
yeah oh oh oh okay so the base of the
food chain
yeah yeah so it's it's great feeding
ground
okay so so the water is dense with with
food
okay yes yeah it's got we've got krill
and
copepods and lots of little swarming
tiny food which is why the whales come
there
but it also means our water is really
cloudy and that
a whale can't see another whale so we
might laugh and say oh why would a whale
talk to another whale
and that's because if you want to know
if someone's around you have to be sound
producing
otherwise the whale is functionally
invisible
dating in the dark
well look at that wait wait so ellen
you're based up in scotland is are there
any whales up in the north atlantic
of course there is uh there are
humpbacks up here but i do
uh my work actually in the south pacific
being from that region so i am beautiful
apparently yeah yeah there's lots of
different populations how far around
because
now i no i think it was humpbacks that
we were watching
i was in hawaii and we went watching
it's during their
breeding time where they go uh i was off
of lanai and maui and
they say the waters are warm and so they
that's where they go
to birth so where where
is the scope of their travel around
because i saw one on the east river just
a few days ago
so and that they do travel thousands and
thousands of kilometers because i work
in kilometers
um so they will spend the summer months
feeding
which is uh where michelle works in the
polar regions and then over winter
they go to the tropical and subtropical
breeding grounds wait
wait wait wait wait winters and summers
are switched from each other northern
southern hemisphere
so quickly so do they cross the equator
they do just around columbia
that costa rica nicaragua that
area on the western side of
the south america but if they have
habits that are seasonally driven
then they can't go too far across the
equator otherwise they'll get completely
flipped
exactly right they go back to the same
breeding location and feeding ground
usually every year they have this really
strong sight fidelity so they'll go
basically uh you guys can see up and
down
so they're how do they do this without
gps
oh that is a really fantastic question
we're not entirely
sure exactly how they navigate it may
have something to do
with um magnetism
and how that style but we're not
entirely sure exactly
so i mean this might be of interest to
you but in addition to magnetism as one
theory
there's also a theory that whales can
actually detect
differences in the gravitational tug of
the earth
and so they use different gravitational
forces to know when and where to migrate
or alternatively as an acquisition this
matters to ellen and i
that they can actually listen to learn
their way around
that they hear what a soundscape sounds
like and they know oh i'm in the right
place or i'm in the wrong place
kind of like you would know the
difference between if you were in a
basketball court or if you were in a
closet
right right so i vote against that
they're feeling
earth's gravitational field i vote i'm
voting against that okay
as like a as like a physicist here as an
astrophysicist
as an astrophysicist because the whale
is basically neutrally buoyant
right and so people say hummus is a
whale way it weighs zero
until you pull it out on land where now
what does it weigh
in air but in water it's it's basically
zero and if you weigh
zero then variations in gravity around
you are kind of irrelevant
because you're just floating there so
that's that's my first
take at that but uh i i could be wrong
let me
before we go to break and then get to
our questions from our fan base let me
just ask you
the um is there any way
dr doolittle could be a documentary
no what i mean is okay let me be more
precise
um all animals that all animals we care
about communicate with each other so
it's just a matter of us learning how to
communicate in that same way can you
imagine a day where we just communicate
with all the animals
the way time lords do in doctor who
for example or the way mary poppins does
when she talked to the dog and the
parrot
all right i'm gonna counter that with a
slightly more complicated question
um should we oh right
exactly that's what i was gonna say
first of all
there's a lot of animals i really don't
want to talk to you
i mean if i'm at a cocktail party i
don't want to talk to a llama
that's all i'm saying all right i may
want to talk to the orangutan
looks like he might have something on
his mind yeah you know what i mean
i certainly want to talk to a humpback
whale you know what i mean do you
remember
but not a chimpanzee they're [ __ ]
they're rude
they throw their poop i don't want to
talk to you
so you mentioned orangutans in a planet
of the apes the orangutans were the
diplomats
so they were the ones that had oh that's
right yeah the gorillas were the police
that's and the chimpanzees were the
academic research
scientists that's right i just want to
throw that out there okay anyway so
let's let's end this segment we're going
to come back and go straight to
questions
this is like marvelous expertise to have
on star talk
because this is like we've all thought
about this and you guys
get to declare your profession and we're
all jealous so we'll be right back on
star talk
cosmic queries we're back star talk
cosmic queries
we're gonna talk to some whales in this
program uh but we need the help of
expert
whale whisperers uh we've got michelle
fordnay she's a marine ecologist
and a postdoctoral fellow at cornell
university right upstate new york
and she specializes in animal
communication and a new term new to me
and i love it
marine bio acoustics i love it and we
got ellen garland a marine biologist
uh currently at the university of saint
andrews in scotland
and you study cricitation
song culture that's just badass
just just and you're both featured in a
documentary
coming out uh very shortly on this whole
subject and it's called
fathom a quick test uh chuck how
long is a fathom um
[Music]
pretty long okay thank you
okay ellen you said you're metric and
fathom is anything but metric how long
is a fathom
oh oh i'm in trouble i'm in trouble ouch
michelle how long are the father six
feet six feet i think she's about right
i think you're right there
that's right there you go okay that's
right all right dodge the bullet there
there we go under the bus already
so can you fathom this that six feet is
not that much
you know when you think about all right
let's go to q a from our our
supporting uh patreon members these
they support our uh what we do and
there's some perks in return yeah they
give us money
can i can i be you know who doesn't like
to say that they support us use words he
likes to use
euphemistic words like support support
and
you know i'm like yeah give us money you
give us money
all right and we'll give you uh but
anyway um uh all seriousness
uh the people from uh patreon give us
the opportunity to
do some things that we otherwise would
not do yeah we experiment and we do
things that are just fun
and we'll let you know when that how and
when that happened all right chuck
give us one let's go to uh tomas
paz and tomas says
hello it seems to me that verbal
communication
underwater or any other liquid would be
difficult
do you think that intelligent life that
lives beneath the surface could
communicate using something else
than sound
that's a really kind of cool concept
you know whales is definitely sound you
know
so ellen what do you think about that
that's a it's a really good question
um i mean underwater you really want to
go for sound i mean
visual communication as michelle was
saying earlier that
you're not going to see that fire
underwater so it's
it is really all about sound um and they
can't send smoke signals right there
a lot of other ways we take for granted
that you can't do underwater
exactly it's a really different
environment and i think
um also you know the chemoreception
um that's not gonna go as far so it's
really
all about sound underwater i'd be really
surprised if there was a
different communication system michelle
did the different frequencies of sound
travel different distances
because just because you're underwater
it doesn't mean sound doesn't work it's
another medium through which
the sound is moving it's just a pressure
wave through the molecules
so that's the physics of it so um
do the whales have they found a special
frequency where they can talk a
gazillion miles around the world
yes actually well a gazillion miles
perhaps not but yes
is the answer to that um so a gazillion
is just
just longer than six feet okay so like a
fathom and a half
and a half so low frequency sound is
what we think of as low pitch
and it means that there's a longer
wavelength so wavelengths actually have
distance you know distance and velocity
and so
your voice kneel is lower than mine so
you'll have a lower frequency voice
which means
theoretically underwater your voice
would travel further than mine would
and that has to do with the physics of
this situation with loss of energy
high frequency sounds have very short
wavelengths and they're used for short
distance communication
and by the way that's true in the air
too i mean that's why
lightning sounds very snap crackle and
poppy when it's right near you
but if it's on the horizon you only hear
the low rumble it lost all the high
frequencies
so exactly yeah yeah yeah so with
whales depending on you know with
cetaceans in general depending on what
the sound
is used for it might be lower frequency
for long distance communication
or it might be very high frequency to be
used for things like echolocation or for
short distance communication
and then because of the physics of sound
underwater because of pressure in the
ocean and temperature
there's actually something called the so
far channel the sound fixing and ranging
channel
which is an area of sound speed minimum
and sound can get trapped in this
underwater channel
and travel for thousands of kilometers
oh
because otherwise it'll just escape and
then you lose it so if you keep it
contained
it'll just reflect back and forth from
these layers i love it
i love it there's a similar layer in the
atmosphere um
it's called the ionosphere and uh am
radio waves when they hit the ionosphere
they actually reflect back down
so you can you can detect am radio who
has an 8 ohm radio anymore
beyond the horizon whereas fm goes
straight out
and it doesn't reflect so i like these
parallels between earth's atmosphere
and the ocean so you're sticking with
you got both of you all sticking with
sound on this one
sound is it yeah okay so can i ask a
question speaking of sound
um when we speak we force air
past our cords they vibrate and it
creates the sound
how do these cetaceans do it do they
force water through the way we do or
how are they producing the sound i'm
going to throw this to michelle because
she has a fantastic answer for this
i do um so
uh whales use air just like we do
they have something that's analogous to
vocal cords which are called vocal folds
so different folds
and um they pass air back and forth
through different
sinus cavities in their brain so unlike
you or i
when we exhale you know air comes out of
our mouth and then we have to take
another inhale
um cetaceans will actually take the
inhale at the surface go underwater
and then move that air around back and
forth across these vocal folds in order
to produce sounds
so well i gotta say chuck they would
make excellent jazz musicians
yes just think about that yeah boys they
could hold a note
forever you could just move it back and
forth in the saxophone
oh my gosh we need that in sebastian's
band
in in um
in the little mermaid was there a way no
there wasn't a whale in his band
no the sebastian had a permit crab band
they were making sure
they're totally missing out oh my gosh
it should have been sebastian in the bio
acoustics
okay you might not have been born yet
when that movie came out
but uh so very cool i like that that's
amazing
all right give me another question keep
it coming all right here we go this
is elliot frost uh do you believe we
could utilize the electromagnetic
spectrum
to attempt to communicate with these
marine mammals in a way to sort of
replicate what it would be like to try
to communicate with a
cosmic society that may not know
how to use the electromagnetic spectrum
in the same way that we do
so wow can we talk to them
and they're not know that we're talking
to them but somehow we
let them know we're talking to them
which i believe he just described the
whole premise
of your documentary
sort of so
i i i'm going to take a stab at this but
i'm hoping that those of you who
understand the
electromagnetic part of that will do a
little bit better um i think that what
we are trying to do is not to
communicate with whales the way that we
want to be communicated with we're
trying to understand how they
communicate with each other
which means that we need to work on
their terms
like we are adopting their way of
perceiving the world
their way of interacting so by the way
this is a famous quote from carl sagan
he was saying why is it we judge animals
intelligence by whether they can
communicate with us but maybe we should
judge our intelligence by whether we can
communicate
with them exactly that is exactly what
we are working on so when you think
about
what might be beyond our earth or
extraterrestrial intelligence
um why is it that we have such an
enormous ego that we assume that
everyone must speak our language instead
of learning to speak theirs
we have intelligent life right here on
this planet and we have not yet
interpreted how it is communicating with
itself
that is a really lovely um analog for
perhaps trying to understand something
otherworldly the audacity of those
animals
elephants dolphins you know any animal
with a brain bigger than ours
yeah so the audacity of us to declare
that we could speak with another animal
elsewhere when we can't speak with the
other animals
in on our own planet so i'm embarrassed
by that fact
let me just say that right now okay uh
so so can wouldn't that be great though
if they
actually because they do have bigger
brains they all spoke our language
like but then when we're around they're
just like everybody shut up
yo here come the dummies shut up
shut up just make some sounds give them
something you know all right guys
let me get a phd off of this sound oh my
goodness
back to our other language guys
like we don't even like we don't even
know what um
half the communication is is for a even
though
i i studied the song which is the mail
display we don't
actually know exactly what it's for
and and that's where we're at so ellen
do you get together with with bird
people because they trying to understand
bird songs how different is this really
it it's it's like a slowed down bird
song in some respects
so if you slow down a bird song it can
sound like a whale and if you speed up a
whale song it can sometimes sound
like a canary um so yeah we we
definitely spend a lot of time with with
bird
people with birdsong people and a lot of
the classification and now
understanding of the structure of song
comes from
birdsong because that was farmer
established before
whale song at least exactly so it's
harder to chase
a whale around than there's a bird right
yes tell me about it
tell me about it just trying to get
these recordings of these males
singing their little hearts out so just
one point relative to the question
and i don't know if this is what he
intended but i don't know where else it
could go if you're going to use
electromagnetic energy you're using
light
of some frequency and that would mean
you would be
showing the whale and its eyeballs would
be seeing
some kind of electromagnetic information
so that would be like
writing or something or some symbol and
by the way that's is that any different
from the
the septupus or whatever you guys call
it in the movie arrival
um that was not sound that and it
technically it was sort of the absence
of light
because it was making these ink drawings
and the ink is absorbing light but that
then becomes the symbol so
have you ever thought of communicating
with them not by song but just by giving
them something to look at
oh are you just so song biased that
that's not even a thought
yeah i'm i'm i'm you know i'm on that
side of the communication
spectrum so i i just i
i'm do passive acoustics so i record
what
they're saying um and what they're
singing i don't try and
uh a good point you can't record what
they're writing because they don't right
well i mean i i think i think there are
aspects there with with the
if we think about the song is really has
a lot of repetition
in it it's really repetitive and
redundant
so you think about whether if you're
trying to get a signal out
you'd want that redundancy built in
because you may only
catch the end of that signal at some
point because if the songs are spreading
out
you may just hear the last little faint
bit of a particular theme or a
particular phrase and you think oh
there's you know there's this this is
the seti philosophy where
you don't want to give a long
dissertation because they might
they might not know that you began it
yesterday and might end it in three days
so you're sending a repeating signal so
it's not that it's redundant it's that
you're just
being sensible about when they might
come into the uh
come into the eavesdropping yeah so that
that with that in mind
how do you determine what is
this whatever phrase or word or whatever
you want to call it
how do you determine what sound to
try to uh decipher
like you know uh like for instance there
are certain things that we know
mean something like help right so even
if you never spoke
english right if you never spoke any
language
and you heard somebody go help like you
would know that is a distress call
right just but if you keep listening
over and over you're like
oh that person's in trouble so how do
you find out like
what the one thing is that you want to
identify okay first
chuck did you become a patreon member
yet because you just you just stole a
patreon
slot there oh i didn't know i'll cut you
slight slack
this one time all right i'm not going to
ask anymore i'm sorry
please proceed i can answer that
question um you you spend
you spend a decade listening first so
that's exactly what we wanted to do was
to find out what is the essential
when somebody screams at you it's
because there's something essential that
is shared among all people
so for whales we looked to find out what
is a sound that is essential to humpback
whale communication
like the whale boat is chasing me help
the whalers want my blubber you know we
wanted to know what is the sound that
all whales produce
that male whales produce that female
whales produce old whales young whales
baby whales
any population animals that will never
that have been separated by
three million years of genetic isolation
still produce
the same sound so that was the sound
that we decided to start with
we said okay this is probably
foundational this is essential
so in order to figure out what that
sounds means now that we've identified
that there's something important
we're going to play it back to them and
see how they respond so if you scream
help and ice cream help we're both in
trouble
luckily the sound doesn't appear to mean
that it's more of a way of
saying to the ocean you know i am and i
am here
and i am me and then other whales will
respond with it i also
am i am here i am me but you told me
they're like dickheart i just got chills
i think therefore i am are you telling
me there's a they got a whale philosophy
that would freak that would freak us out
if we found out that they had philosophy
class
that's so cool oh my god that's so cool
do you want to hear what it sounds like
yes yeah you guys yes
and this is important for ellen's work
too because this is a sound that appears
in song pretty regularly
the call is called a whoop call and it
sounds
is what the sound sounds like so that is
a sound that humpback wheels worldwide
all produce
wait wait do that again
wow wow it sounds like a
voice warm-up before you go in and on
that's what they're doing underwater wow
so so a quick
we got to wrap this segment and come
back with more questions from our
audience if chuck doesn't keep stealing
those slots
is a couple of things underwater a
particular vibrational frequency
underwater is now vibrating in a denser
medium so that its frequency will change
so you just gave me a sound that i'm
hearing in air
or is that is that what it sounds like
underwater and you're giving it an air
version of it
or do you need that underwater and it's
going to take on its own frequency
profile
so that's what it sounds like underwater
at close range got it wow
and and so uh i thought there was a
clever you know i'm not a i'm not a
whale person maybe you guys thought this
was the stupidest thing ever
but i thought it was a clever element of
of the
star trek four okay uh the voyage home
which is otherwise known as save the
whales right and i know you've seen
those movies the the series and in it
there's a sound they can't interpret and
was it spock who figured out
let us immerse the sound on the water
and then everyone said that's a whale
sound
and so uh do you give him credit for
thinking that far through on that plot
line
sure yeah absolutely okay
yeah i'm just just checking yeah i mean
the way that sound propagates through a
medium like how sound propagates through
water is very different
than how sound propagates through air
you and in this case the medium is very
closely coupled with the sound producer
so if you make a sound in water and if
that same animal were to even attempt to
make it an air probably wouldn't work
to your point the sound propagation
changes according to density
and temperature and hence you get these
what do you call the so far lane or
something the so far channel
so far yeah you have to be in the sofa
channel for that to work so if you were
to vocalize under it or above it your
sound wouldn't travel as far
very very cool let's take a quick break
and when we come back
chuck shut up okay
no we need you to give the questions and
we'll get as many as we can
uh when we return when we figure out how
to talk to wales on star talk
we're back star talk third and final
segment we're trying to find out how to
talk to animals
if you're not dr doolittle but we have
our
own version of dr doolittles here in
michelle
fournet and ellen garland and their
expertise is precisely what we need to
have this
conversation so let's do this chuck you
collected questions about talking to
whales
yes let's continue uh i love this
question from
chris plotz and chris says how big of a
problem is
noise pollution in the oceans is there
something we can do to mitigate the
effects
while keeping our supply lines intact
and then i'll put an addendum on it
because it's his question
how great was the last year when all the
shipping and everything
but it's also true ellen isn't it right
that most commerce
travels on shipping lanes so that in
principle
maybe the whales could adjust to that
but otherwise yeah each of these
each of these boats has got a big
outboard motor or inboard motor
it's not just rowers ben hurst style or
whatever
exactly there's a lot of low frequency
sound being put into the ocean which
can interfere with the uh communication
range of particularly the big baleen
whales which
communicate over those long distances
and of course there are
shipping lanes so those can be
moved a little bit if it's on a
migratory route
at least we can understand where the
whales are starting to go
and when and trying to minimize these
overlaps
and this interference um in their sound
space between
the whales and on our shipping because
we do need to move stuff around the
world but we also need to
provide quieter locations at particular
times of the year that's really
important for the whales say
uh when they're when they're giving
birth in particular uh
carving grounds and mating grounds just
to make sure that
they're able to hear each other so that
they can find each other
if you can't find them if you can't hear
a mate you can't find a mate
to actually reproduce and i can tell you
this
uh you it seems to me you don't want to
piss off a whale
because whatever boat you're in the
whale's going to win
that's what it seems to me i'm thinking
i'm just thinking i don't know
if you're in a small boat you really do
not want to irritate a whale
yeah i mean you don't want to do that
that's nice i've seen i saw
i saw a youtube video of a whale it was
did some
out of spite i know it it was like they
were poking at it and stuff and this
whale came up and just
just slapped it slapped its tail down
and it didn't quite capsize the boat but
you know
even if it's not true let me keep
thinking that because that was it was a
beautiful thing
but they used to call gray whales devil
fish in the sea of cortez because if you
would separate a cow from her calf she
would actively go after the boat
so it was a this horrible tactic where
they would try to do that to draw the
the bigger whales in
so yes they they don't mess with the
mama whale
oh yeah nice oh yeah do not mess with i
like it
i like it that's very mammal of them
that's what mammals do right we protect
our young
right yeah well i i've have a comment
about the covid thing because we just
wrapped up some really cool new research
on this
um we dropped hydrophones in alaska
during covet and the year before so
what is that what's a hydrophone oh an
underwater microphone it's how we listen
to the whales
okay hydro as in water and then phone as
in okay hydrophone cool yeah
a new word for me i like that yeah so we
put hydrophones down in 2019
to listen to whales and also just to
document ship traffic so that we can
answer that noise question that your
caller had about it
um but what we did when the pandemic hit
was we dropped another hydrophone
and in certain parts of alaska we
documented a threefold decrease in noise
associated with the pandemic
but this is even this is even a bigger
deal there was a 25
decrease in the loudest part of the day
so when ships would pass over our
hydrophone in 2019
it was 25 times louder
than the loudest moments during the
pandemic and we noticed a change
in how humpback wheels communicate in
quiet
versus how humpback whales communicate
in noise
what we know well that makes sense yeah
i mean we do the same thing
i mean anybody who's been to a nightclub
knows that
you don't you don't come home from work
and go so haunted
like you don't do that yep exactly
yeah all right good good wow cool man
that is really cool stuff all right keep
it going chuck let's let's keep going
this is the last segment i want to make
sure you get as many as many questions
as we can
all right they'll have they'll have
another chance
how often do we have whale whisperers on
the show just
all right point taken okay here we go
this is uh our friend violetta
and her mom uh izzy who says uh
other animals communities just because
if i let it this 12 year old violence 12
year old
is she 13 yet she's been asking
questions for like for the last 20 years
[Laughter]
that's hilarious all right violetta all
right so violetta
uh who wants to be an astrophysicist by
the way let's not forget that
she says other animals communicate using
sound frequencies and
wavelengths of light that humans can
neither see
nor hear so what is the coolest craziest
means of communication that you guys
have ever encountered in
any other species oh
okay i have my i have my vote i know
what my vote is but go ahead okay
so ellen why don't you start that
that's a great question isn't that an
awesome question
i'm i'm kind of stumped i i i mean
violet you're not supposed to stump the
experts
yeah hey guys let's remember this is a
12 year old
you keep stopping the experts we're
gonna have to cancel you okay
so i reckon i've i've heard some really
strange sounds be made by a humpback
because whenever
anyone's like oh can you play me some
song they want this gorgeous
really harmonic what what you guys
used to hear on records and you know
they can make some horrifically screechy
horribly groany high frequency sounds as
well
and they're really just not i was
incredibly surprised when i actually
started listening to humpback song
that they make this whole variety of
sounds
um from from the lower frequencies
through the
they almost whistle okay maybe some of
it is just simply not songs
that's all yeah well
i have the best or maybe i mean when you
listen to our songs and maybe it's just
like hey welcome to w-h-a-l-e radio
yeah we got some we got some cetaceous
death metal definitely
that's what it is right that's what it
is it's heavy metal
cetaceous music whoa
we know where ellen's tastes lie now
but so michelle do you have it what's
the weirdest form of communication
you've seen
whales or otherwise i've got two
so i think the one that always blows my
mind that i don't study and i've never
seen
but anyone who had was a beekeeper could
is this
is the waggle dance dance yeah so bees
communicate
the location of their food by dancing so
they do this sort of waggle and they
waggle their little bee butts
and they do it in such a specific way
that they can actually convey all this
crazy information to the other members
of their hives
and i'm a terrible dancer if i were to
do a waggle dance you wouldn't get far
and i think that is just one of the
coolest ways
your whole colony would go extinct if
they had to depend on you to waggle this
that's what you're saying sure i mean my
sense of direction is bad when i'm using
words even worse when i'm middling it
moving
well let me tell you something be
twerking has got to be up there with the
best
okay that's what they're doing the twerk
is like doing this
that's the best that's the best waggle
dance we actually devoted b
we devoted a whole episode in cosmos
the other one is it's a sound but we
can't hear it um
elephants produce something called a
rumble which is
an infrasonic sound so we all you know
there's really wavelengths too high for
us to see these are sounds too low
frisco
and so people for a long time didn't
even think that they were communicating
at all
and katie payne who's a researcher and
also my neighbor um
she actually started thinking about the
fact that these elephants were
communicating with sound that that
actually transmitted through the ground
and then could be detected so that again
those long that low frequency goes
farther
in the same way that in air and in water
so that's that's
wow and through solids so because i mean
sound travels further through water than
air but it travels even further through
a solid than it does through water
the denser than medium right that makes
putting your ear on a railroad track
very effective
yeah you can hear very far away until
you fall asleep
i'm morbid
let me nestle up against this cold steel
track
all right keep it see more we can get in
here keep going all right here we go
all right by the way mine was chemical
uh communication
through like the way ants do oh yeah
so cool all right here we go uh my
favorite would be
when the aliens come and then we
communicate telepathically that'll be
when
that's what i'm looking forward to okay
get out of my head bellzap
all right so what your alien is called
mine's cool
all right keep it coming zach metcalf
wants to know this good morning from
atlantic canada
austrian philosopher ludwig
uh witchenstein said
if a lion could talk we could not
understand him
his point was that consciousness has
taken radically different forms
in different animals is this a valid
concern when conversing with
intelligent marine mammals such as
dolphins
and whales let me let me shape that a
little differently i'd like that
question but i want to sort of
focus it a little differently we when we
study human brains we can isolate
the language center and you know the
communication centers
so is there similar sort of uh you know
ekg or mris done on whale brains
to you need you need a machine big
enough to stick them in
to do this but do we do they have
language centers as we do and if that's
the case
um do they have the same motives
as we would when we as we try to
communicate i
i can take a step at that unless ellen
you want to go for it i'm happy for you
to take a stab at that okay
it's pretty hard to figure out
that's the first part yeah we humpback
whales heads are 15 feet long and
8 000 pounds so um getting them in an
mri is tricky
um but i mean just squeeze it in that's
what
brain matter is pretty squeezy i think
right yeah but
the skull perhaps is not um
but one of the big differences in how
cetaceans communicate how humans
communicate we have language in that we
have
representational acoustic signals i i
this is my hand
i have a hand a whale doesn't have a
word for flipper
um a whale doesn't have a word for fish
all of the sounds that whales make to
our knowledge again we don't we don't
know
how a whale perceives the world or even
really how it hears very well
but the way that they um communicate and
interpret is through action function and
motivation
and so they might have a sound that is
associated with foraging
they might have a sound that's
associated with reproduction
but it's true that you can't translate
whale because it's not representational
speech
now there is this really great principle
called motivation structure theory
that or motivational structure theory
that mammals and many terrestrial
vertebrates share
that um fearful sounds are sort of high
intriguing
scary sounds are low and growly and rar
and that we can translate
the different sounds of pitch and
timbre to understand something about
motivation
which is like a scientific it's like a
science-friendly way of saying emotion
it's like chuck saying help that's kind
of you know that gets around even if you
don't
interpret the word exactly exactly so
there will be
commonalities in how mammals produce
sounds when they are
feeling a certain way and we probably
share some of that with whales
um but in terms of being able to say our
language can be translated into whale
that's not true they're not they're not
tool users they're not holding no
right by the way i mean it wouldn't make
sense for them
to be in that position anyway when you
think about it
all of our existence is predicated upon
being able to make associations and
references
we we couldn't survive if we didn't do
that
whereas whales i mean their environment
they are
they are one with their environment
right you know
you know we still don't completely
understand their communication system
we're only starting to scratch the surfa
surface of trying to understand what
some of these displays are what some of
these
particular sound types mean or if
exactly if they're just associated with
a particular behavioral
setting we are only just scratching the
surface
chuck we got time for one more question
bring it on all right so this one i'm
gonna
this is our last one this is baya miceli
uh says or michelle says this
i'm just going to be the person to ask
it nobody
else will
[Laughter]
is there even a slight possibility
that mer people have ever existed
okay oh somebody had to go there
somebody had to go there somebody had to
go there well let me ask it another way
i i learned embarrassingly late in life
that whales didn't evolve in the ocean
they
their ancestors were land mammals that
somehow decided they'd rather
swim for a living and so at some point
you might have had the mammal that could
just do both
well i might i might go the opposite way
on that and say um
mer people don't currently exist but
some of us could start our way back
and wow if i mean evolution brought
brought mammals into the ocean you know
we had fish and the fish eventually came
to land and then we had all these
evolutionary diversions
um in the same way that whales returned
to the ocean
um give it enough time and enough
impetus and enough evolutionary drift
and
random genetic drift and mer people
perhaps might exist
at some point in the very very very very
very far future
chuck sounds like she's got a plan
the first thing of course is to learn
the language of the whales so that you
know how to say hello when you get there
oh right right and here's something a
little bit of trivia in
what's the tom hanks movie with um uh
splash in splash the with daryl hannah
as the mermaid uh all scenes underwater
there are no bubbles coming out of her
at all
so this was an attempt to show how
natural she was underwater
and that she's not trying to just hold
her breath or anything that's just where
she hangs out
and so apparently she has gills uh they
didn't otherwise make that clear
but yeah so that's that's uh then
there's always the shape of water
where you know you just there's
you know there's got to be some sexy
people in the ocean
okay so here's my last point that i was
going to make
so let's say you guys succeed and you
figure out
how to communicate with whales in their
language in ways that they understand
wouldn't this completely freak them out
see suppose we were unwittingly being
studied
by cats okay let's say and then
that's not a stretch and then one day
they all decide it is time
and then a cat just goes up the white
house lawn
and says pardon me i'd like to speak
with your president
i'm pretty sure we would shoot the cat
all right we
we would kill the cat we don't want any
talking cats
here so is there is
are you okay doing this they'll see a
different species
giving them information that they give
each other and that
is how about their psychological health
no
the goal is for the whales to never know
we're there
we only we only do this work so that we
can understand them
the goal is not to start a conversation
that we're going to have for ages and
ages
the goal is not to start a relationship
this is like this is very star trek
uh it is prime direction that is the
best example
yes we have a prime directive not to
interfere
but we do want to understand to conserve
something
to protect its existence we have to we
have to demonstrate to the scientific
community and to everyone that it has
value
it has to be important so the only
reason that we are doing something as
audacious
as talking to a whale is so that we can
understand what they say to each other
not to have this concept that they are
supposed to talk to us
and if we do our job well they will have
what seems to be a completely natural
unobtrusive interaction with a sound
that they experience every day
and that they will continue living their
totally natural lives
oblivious to our existence that's it
that is beautiful okay wait wait
in our world it's called eavesdropping
that's called wiretapping
that's called we have to say
so wait now wait a minute one one one
quick thing though
let's say um you do figure out you
decode
you see this is you're able to
understand with great clarity
and what you find out is that what
they're really talking about
is or let's just say you hear this the
plan to exterminate all human life
is on track going well
and we'll conclude in the next
six months what do you do there
hey so everyone ellen i want to give you
guys i'm getting thrown yeah
i mean i i i i would be very surprised
if that if that was
what was being i'm glad you'd be
surprised by that because if not
but alan take us out with some
concluding reflections
on what you do and what we can look
forward to
so i i'm trying to
investigate how songs are shared across
ocean basins how whales are learning
these
really complex vocal displays that
only the males are doing so they're
trying to understand
who they're singing to whether they're
singing to females
or to other males to say hi i'm a big
mature male and
i'm ready to major i'm big and strong go
away
and how these population level cultures
are then
shared between these populations
across an entire ocean basin so we have
these really amazing
vocal cultures all of these incredible
vocal cultures
in the oceans unbelievable man
well you know there's more ocean than
land and so
and the ocean goes really deep and land
is pretty flat
so maybe we shouldn't have not we should
not be surprised by any of this
that the ocean is where it's at and i
like michelle's plan to breed
uh mer people so quick we'll check back
in on you michelle see how they're
coming along there
yep new career trajectory for me i just
discovered it now okay
all right so guys we gotta call it quits
there this has been a delight to have
both of you
on this cosmic queries and the subject
is so
rich and so scientifically and
culturally interesting
that uh we're i'm sure we haven't seen
the end of this
so if you want to catch that documentary
fathom and you
missed it at the film festival you can
check it out on apple tv plus
that's where you can go to learn
something for a change
given all the time we're spending
binging sitcoms
throw in a documentary every now and
then and
get a little closer to our own planet
in which we live this has been star talk
cosmic queries tyson
keep looking
[Music]
you